[拍手]
はいみなさんこんにちは
ご紹介にあずかりましたキンダーリープと
いうおもちゃをやっております杉本と言い
ます
私はですねまぁ若いころにドイツで暮らし
たという経験がありましてそれがきっかけ
でドイツのおもちゃのお店をやっており
ますでまああのちょっと変わったお店なん
ですけれどもどんなことをやっているかと
いいますと
お店の中でですね
遊んでお客さんと一緒に過ごすで面白かっ
たら買っていただく
これはまあ積み木を積んでますけれども私
のお気に入りはですね積み木でしてもう
ほぼ毎日のようにお店の前の通路に
はみ出して積み木を積んだりしてました
お店がですねー
北海道の小樽にあるんですけれどもお客
さんがですねものすごく遠方から来ること
に驚きました網走とかですね
稚内とかからいらっしゃるんですそれは何
を意味するかというとそういうを持ちたの
お店がですね近くにないとですね欲しい人
はわざわざそんだけの距離を走って
いらっしゃるということなんです
私には衝撃でした
ですので何をしたかと言いますと
こちらから出向いていきますよ始めました
このキャンピングカー仕様のバスがですね
後ろ半分が和室になってまして
そこでおもちゃで遊べるような移動プレイ
コーナー月の
移動おもちゃ号というのをするために九州
までこの車を買いに行きまして北海道まで
乗って帰ってきたりしたんですけれどもで
この車でですね
あっちこっち行くわけですけれども
あの
まあ
これはね外のイベントの時の写真です
けれども扱ってるおもちゃですね割と教育
玩具
まあ一派借りやすい言葉で言えばチーク
玩具みたいなものなんですけれども売り方
はですね的屋のおっちゃんぽいんですね
普通この手のおもちゃ屋さんはですね割と
先生ぽい方がやってます
なのであのこういう風お祭りに出てくる
あの
物販のおじさんみたいなことあんまり皆
さんなさらないんですが私はですねどうも
キャラが
駄菓子屋のおっちゃんなんですね
でですねー
これはですね東北の震災の時にですね
支援ボランティアみたいなのに行った時の
写真なんですけれども
本子供とは限らないわけですお年寄りの
いらっしゃるところに行って一緒に
あそぼうやるわけですねそうするとですね
だんだん私のやっていることはあの玩具の
販売というよりはおもちゃを使った
コミュニケーションを届ける
それが子供大人お年寄り関係ないっていう
ようななんですねそういう展開になってき
たんですねですので私が行くと楽しい時間
が始まるぞって子供たちは思うようになっ
てですね私の顔を見ただけで嬉しそうな
笑顔になるんですよね
こんな幸せなことは
私の人生で初めてでした
やがてですね
おもちゃの話をしてくださいという仕事が
来るようになりまして
これどういうことかと言いますと
まあ主に幼児教育の世界でですね絵本とか
玩具っていうのは非常に重要な扱いを受け
ています
で絵本のお話をする人は実はたくさん
いらっしゃいます日本はですね方が
素晴らしいレベルにあるんですねなので
絵本のことを話す講師はたくさん
いらっしゃるんですねそれに控えです
おもちゃがまあ人がいないから私に依頼が
来ると言ったらなんですけれども
おもちゃの話をしてくださいと言われる
わけですね
で私はですねー
人前でしゃべるな本当は大の苦手でした
若い時はもうほとんど対人恐怖症といって
よかったと思いますけれども
それなのにですね人前で話す仕事を
だんだんとを受けるようになってきました
受けるしかないんです方墳4
私以外にあまりやる人はいない仕事ですし
ストレイにですねまぁ北海道で関西弁で
しゃべるせいかもしれませんが割と面白
がってもらえたんですねはいでもですねー
ええ
そこに至るまでの道筋はですねそんな簡単
ではなかったんです
私はですね
実は若い時はドイツに住んでました
ですので
え
ドイツでですね色んな事にチャレンジした
んですね
ですから皆さんはきっとドイツに行って
ドイツのすごいいいおもちゃに出会って
日本に帰ってきてドイツのおもちゃのお店
を開いたと思われると思うんですがじつは
そんな簡単ではなかったんです
私はですね実は40歳の時に初めて
おもちゃをオープンしましたので40歳
まではですね何をしていたかというと
いろんなことをやってましたがその中の一
つがドイツに行っていろんなチャレンジ
でしたが何と私ドイツ政府の失業保険を
もらった経験があります
あまりかっこよく言う話ではないんです
けれども
えでもそれは私の人生で貴重な1年間だっ
たと思います
その時間にまあドイツ語の勉強をしたり
いろんなボランティア活動をしたり
まあ非常に貴重な経験をしたんですけれど
も
でもですねそれで何か目標を見つけて日本
に帰っておもちゃになったというほど話は
簡単ではなかったんですね
それどころかですねえ私はドイツに行く前
は日本でサラリーマンをしてたんです
けれども
その時はもう本当に仕事がいい嫌で嫌で
もうほとんど出社拒否に近いぐらいに嫌々
働いてました
でですねなんでそんなことになってしまっ
たかと言いますとさらにその前を遡ると私
はもともと子供の時はですね優等生タイプ
だったんですねで学校の成績が良かった
わけです
でそれをですねまあ非常に勘違いして学歴
で生きていけるという風に思い込んでたん
ですよね
ところがですねまぁ社会人になる頃には
だんだんそういうパワーが薄れてまして
実社会に出たらですね
まあ
同僚たちたまたま車の会社だったんですが
結構やんちゃ出身の同票等がですねええ
クルマに関しては私より遥かに詳しいくっ
て
仕事の成績も私より良いということがあり
ました
これは実は非常にショックだったんです
けれども
ちょっと自信を喪失したんですね
でまぁそれもあってあの挽回したいと思っ
て一大チャレンジでドイツに渡ったんです
けれども
実はですねドイツでもまあいろんなことを
やったんですけどこれで生きていこうと
いうようなものには残念ながら出会え
なかった
そしてドイツでもですねやはり
サラリーマンの時と同じように好きなこと
をやってる日本人がいたんですよね私の
場合はたまたまであったらオートバイの
メカニックの人たちでしたけれども要は
オートバイが好きでオートバイをいじって
いるうちに行けそれをする仕事ができて
いる間
ki 私はですねも外国大学出身ですねで
語学が大事だったんですねなのでドイツ語
の学習には一生懸命にあったんですけれど
も
二刀
我をに帰るとそのドイツ語の知識を生かし
て何をするのかという大目標が全く
見つからなかったんです
ですのでですね
実はドイツから帰ってくるときには非常に
中途半端な状態で何をやってたかというと
一番恥ずかしいドイツの失敗はちょっとお
話ししますが看護師になろうと目標立て
ましてドイツの看護学校に入学してなんと
ドイツの看護師免許を取ろうとしたんです
ね
でもそれはですね私の能力をはるかに超え
たチャレンジでした
で挫折しましてもう
中ぐらいになっているときに頭の地震が
起こったんですね
で頭私はまあ埋まり子今日は頭ですので
これは日本に帰ろうと思って
ドイツ生活をたたんで帰ったわけです
けれども
ほとんども一文でした
そこから
すごいおもちゃになったかというとまださ
さらに8年くらい時間がかかってるんです
ね
ですので
そんな簡単な話ではなかったので私はです
ねその人生の失敗の前半40歳でおもちゃ
になるまでの時間は無駄に終わったと
ずっと思ってました
浪費してしまったと思ってたんですね
ところがですねだんだんそうじゃなくなっ
てきました
おもちゃの話に戻りますけれどもおもちゃ
をですね得るためにいろいろやっている
うちにですねおもちゃの背景にあるものに
興味が湧いてきました
例えば赤ちゃんはですねおしゃぶりとか
握り玩具は面白いなあまあ皆わかるんです
けれどその後ですねこういうものを渡すと
叩きたくなるんですねでこれは持っていた
とやるともいたずらですのでやめなさいと
言われます100%大人止めますね
でも赤ちゃんは大人を困らせようと思って
やってないんですね実はこれは生まれて
初めて使う道具であって道具が使えるから
嬉しいので叩きたいんですねでまぁ実際に
は叩くための受けがあってハンマートーイ
という一つのお茶になっててそれを叩いて
ねって言うとダメって言わないでこれを
叩いていいよって言えるんですそれは肯定
的なメッセージなんですねそうすると
すごくうれしくってだんだんこれが上手に
叩けるようになるみたいなですねおもちゃ
のバックグラウンドがわかってくると
ちょっと目からうろこになってきました
積み木というものがありますけれどもこれ
をですね
まあ赤ちゃんは弄ってるだけなんです
けれども
ある時こう詰む可能性があるわけですね
でものを積んだら規則正しく並べたらある
形になるっていう発見はすごいことだと
思います
考えてみれば人間は物を使って社会を
つくっててすべてのものはものを規則
正しくきれいに並べることで建築とかに
なっていくわけですからそのはじまりの
はじまりみたいなことを
赤ちゃんは既にやってるわけですね
赤ちゃんばかりではありません例えば
幼児車なんとかですね学童になったとし
ましょう
楽器というものも扱ってますけれども
[音楽]
我々大人はですねついつい
上手に演奏して欲しい4曲を弾けることが
目的だと思いがちですが実際にはですね
いい音に感動することが目的なんですね
これは大人よく勘違いするんですけれども
えおえかきなんかでも上手に作品を書こう
とさせますけれども
そういうことが本来目的ではないんですね
色を楽しむ
自分が塗ることが喜びであるみたいな世界
が確かにあるんですね
これはうまくいくとアートにつながって
いくかなと思っています
あるいはですね
昔遊びでお手玉というものがありますが今
のかこれは1個がこれができない子が多い
です
こんな感じなんですね
ですのでその子たちに23個渡して
ジャグリングみたいなことをさせようと
思ってもうまくいきません
こういう時はですねちょっと努力したら
できそうなことをやってみせます例えば
これができるようになったらちょっと画面
の向こうの皆さんハンカチ丸めていっぺん
行ってみてください消しゴムでもいいです
これができるようになったらこれです
この時に変えるのようにて酔っぱっと広げ
ないと
こうなるわけですね
でこれができるようになったらこんな上
から撮るを入れて思って裏上を持って裏上
とやるとですねこれくらいはできるように
なるんですね子供たちはそうすると達成感
が出てきて次のレベルをにチャレンジし
たくなります
幼児教育の世界で最近接領域という言葉が
ありまして
もっとも近く接する領域と書くんです
けれども
要はですねちょっと頑張ればできそうな
ことには人間は行ってみようと思って
チャレンジするということなんですねで
子どもの場合はですね遊びの中で
チャレンジしていると言われています
滑り台を滑る時でも毎回違う滑り方をする
という説もあるくらいなんですこれは大人
にはなかなかできないことなんですけれど
も
ですのでですねえチャレンジするときに
無理なチャレンジではなく頑張ったら
あと一歩踏み出せばできそうなところを
やるということは非常に重要なんですね
あるいはですね
理科のおもちゃというものがあります
ちょっと怪しいんですけどやってみ
ましょうかね
あおちゃん沈みなさ
赤ちゃん沈みなさーい
赤ちゃん起きなさーい
あおちゃん起きなさーい
ねシーンとなりますけれども
理科の教材ですねで水圧とか
アルキメデスの源流とかの時に使うんです
けれども
これが不思議だうっていうことが大事なん
ですね
不思議って非常に重要なキーポイントです
なのでこれがですねぇ
これ理科の先生が使うものなんですけど
まぁ種明かし止めておきましょうか
もう一ついきましょう
今度はですね
gigi に回りなさいです
あるいは左に回りなさいです
シーンとなりますねこの不思議感がですね
なぜなんだっていうふうに向かうわけです
これは答えがあります理科なので答えが
あるジャンルなんですでこうやってですね
理科の興味につながっていく可能性がある
んですねということでですね遊びの中には
人の人生に重要なアートであったり
スポーツであったり
学問であったりに取り組むきっかけになる
ものがたくさんあるんです
やがてですね私はこんな風に考えるように
なりました
あの人生というのはですね非常にシンプル
にできるかもしれないということですね
まず子供はですね食べると眠るが書ければ
ダメなのはもうみんなわかるんですけれど
も遊ぶことが重要だということはですね
なかなかわからないんですね
ほっといても遊ぶというのが子供の
イメージなんですが子供頭遊ばないと
おかしくなりますこれですね成長して若者
にあるとどうなるかというと
食べる眠るは一緒ですね
でも若者はですね
学ぶと思ってますこの学ぶと遊ぶがですね
私が子供の頃は逆さまの行為だと思ってた
んですけど実は同じ方向だということに気
がついてきました遊ぶエネルギーが家から
形を変えて学ぶエネルギーなるって言う
ことが確かにある
まあ勉強が面白くて仕方がないっていう人
はたまにいますよね
あれはみんなにも本当はそういう可能性が
あるかなと思うんですがじゃあ大人になっ
たときにどうなるかといいますと
働くなんですね
でこれが私がサラリーマンの時に働くのが
嫌で嫌で仕方がなかったことへの自分なり
の答えかと思うんですが楽しくて仕方が
ない働き方ってできるんじゃないかなと
思い出しました
もちろんそれは楽をするという意味では
ないと思います
楽しいけど努力もするわけですね
それがですねー
遊びから学び働けへとつながる
人の生き方の
根本エネルギーみたいなものがですね
何か人間の中には本来あって
それはですね
本当は簡単に出てくるものかもしれないと
思ってます
遊びはですねー
自分でこれをやりたいっていう風に自分
から体を動かして取り組まないと意味が
ないと言われています要はヤラセではダメ
なわけですねだから自主性が大事です
でさらにですね何をやるかは自分が選ば
ないとダメなんですね選ぶ権利があるから
こそ自由に遊べるわけですから自由がない
とダメなんです
ですけれども一番大事なもしかしたら
これはまぁ難しいことかもしれませんが
無目的に遊ぶということが重要だと言われ
ています
遊びは遊びのために遊ぶのであって何かの
目的のために遊んじゃダメだっていうこと
なんですね
この辺の話をですね私はお茶葉でやり
ながらだんだんと悟ってきました
ですので
遊びの意味ということがですね非常に
私の人生にとって
へ前半のね失敗ばっかりの
無駄だと思ってた人生が今になって非常に
意味を持ってきたのももしかしたら遊びか
もしれないなぁと思っております
今日は最後にですね私の非常に
大事な言葉を
皆さんにお送りして終了させていただき
ます
大人になってからあなたを支えてくれるの
は子供時代のあなたです
石井桃子さんというね児童文学者の方の
言葉ですけれどもこの言葉とともに今日は
終了させていただきますご静聴ありがとう
ございました
[拍手]